so we know exactly how AI is doing what
it's doing it has a corpus of billions
of words it is looking for what word is
the next word in the sentence most
likely to occur and then it adds a
slight randomization so it doesn't
become banal and gives you the next word
it does not quote understand what it is
doing I think that's how our brains work
too I think we are talking without
knowing the whole sentence before we say
it and we have a commentary in our head
that is giving the play-by-play that we
call Consciousness that happens after
our brain has already decided what to do
not before and so free will is an
illusion and as someone who's spending
it half an hour an hour a day with AI I
have a lot of trouble reminding myself
that it's not conscious it's just so
much easier to imagine its
intentionality